Let's talk about kinetic energy.
We're calling kinetic
energy K, and it's
given by 1/2mv squared.
And this is a scalar quantity.
So it's going to be
either 0 or positive.
It's never going to be negative.
The SI unit for kinetic
energy is joule,
so we have one joule
here for kinetic energy.
And the units come from this,
so we have kilogram and then
meter per second squared.
Now, let's assume we have an
object that is first at rest
and then it speeds up with
a certain velocity, which
means the object is
going to experience
a change in kinetic energy.
And so we'll express this
as 1/2mv final squared
minus 1/2mv initial squared.
And if we have a
motion, so velocity in,
let's say a 2D or
a 3D space, then
we have to consider all
these components here
and we can also
pull out the 1/2m,
and then we have
vx final squared
plus vy final squared
plus vz final squared
and then minus all the initial
values, x initial, y initial,
and z initial.
Now when we consider
just a point particle,
then we can also ask
what is the momentum?
How can we pair up momentum
and kinetic energy?
So I'm writing it again
here, k equals 1/2mv squared.
If we multiply this by m
upstairs and downstairs,
we're going to have m
squared over v squared,
and that's actually p squared.
Remember p equals mv.
And so we're going to get that
this actually can be expressed
as p squared over 2m.
And so that is
the kinetic energy
expressed in terms of the
momentum of a particle.